one ghostly quest two new love birds and
three vanished serpents we're back river
babe so let's freak out together on
Sweetwater secrets Oh River babes I've
missed you so much
I'm your south side repping host Liana
Galera and this is our Sweetwater
secrets after show for episode 309
chapter 44 no exit aka our first new
episode of 2019 now today I've got
exclusive interviews for you from
Vanessa Morgan KJ app'
and Charles Melton talking all about
this week's biggest plot twists so get
excited for that has anyone ever told
you you're a badass but right now I'm
gonna be really honest with you guys
like I always do this is definitely not
one of my favorite episodes of the
season sorry I said it what did we do we
didn't get any answers about the
quarantine there was a weird dream
sequence and there was a lot of little
conflicts that did not add up to really
anything and did it push the storyline
forward do you agree or disagree with me
start telling me in the comments below
but in the meantime I want to quickly
recap the biggest headlines of the
episode in the blue and gold breakdown
like I said this episode was a bit may
for me so I'm going to do a SuperSpeed
version of what you need to know we
started off with a five-week time jump
after the quarantine why five weeks I
have no flippin clue but we do know that
dark haired Archie has been acting as a
park ranger thing kind of whatever and
staying in a random cabin in the woods
he apparently gets attacked by a bear
because okay sure why not and in his
pain field delirium he hallucinates a
game of Griffin's and gargoyles that's
filled with ghosts of his past giving
him quests mine aren't
time to play he had to confront the
black hood kill a make-believe Hiram and
beat the hell out of himself with a
baseball bat yes I'm serious by the end
of the episode we're supposed to believe
that Archie's fate is up in the air but
come on this is Riverdale they're not
gonna kill Archie it sure feels like it
doesn't meanwhile Betty is playing
babysitter to all the little teens she
rescued from the sisters of quiet mercy
and they really started to get on my
nerves so I was actually relieved when
Evelyn ever never showed up and then
Edgar kind of kidnapped them and took
them all to the farm you'll need
my like five minutes oh and those nuns
were supposed to testify against Hiram
Lodge but instead they were bailed out
of jail and then they all ascended with
the gargoyle King aka they killed
themselves it was weird
Veronica was still fighting with her dad
because of course she was so she
enlisted the help of Jughead and the
Serpent's to act as bodyguards against
Hiram's gang of gargoyles but tensions
with the Serpent's came to a head as
Sherrill Tony and fangs broke jugheads
new post quarantine rules Cheryl and
Tony were acting as two sexy cat
burglars and fangs was dealing fizzle
rocks to help pay for his mom's medical
bills
unfortunately Jughead was forced to
strip them of their jackets and kick
them out of the gang we'll go but we're
keeping our jackets fine actually only
Cheryl and Tony were forced to leave
fangs is now going to act as a double
agent and infiltrate the gargoyle gang
oh that was harsh that was a lot are you
upset with all the sudden serpent
shakeups yeah so is Vanessa Morgan so
here's what the actors actually had to
tell me when I sat down with her on set
talk to me about the tensions that drew
between Cheryl and Jughead within the
serpent's what's going on there I think
the tension between Cheryl and jacket is
that you know Cheryl's used to being the
queen
you know Queen on campus and you know
she's leader of the Vixens
and wherever she go she just couldn't
want to take over or take charge of the
room and coming into the gang where she
was welcomed I think her instinct was
just to take over and I think that's
where they were butting heads cuz you
know Chuck his father was the king so
like him coming down and inheriting that
and her trying to take over that's where
the you know the conflict was so it
definitely makes sense because you have
two people trying to lead and strong
personalities I'm a serpent by blood the
serpents have been her family she grew
up in them and of course it was great
welcoming her girlfriend into it but do
you feel like she was conflicted yeah I
definitely feel like she was conflicted
I think it was one of those things where
she became like obsessed as her like
loved her and just like yet being the
Serpent's like I want you with me I want
you part of my life and maybe shouldn't
realize that that's something that she
should have kept separate yeah you know
like the Serpent's and the guys and
because that seems to be where their
conflict is coming from now giving up a
part of her life
and maybe taking on too much of Cheryl's
life which is causing all the friction
so I didn't think she expected it to be
this way but I think Tony could be
missing you know the boys and that she
you know lost while becoming part of
Cheryl's life
alright River babes do you agree with
Vanessa do you think that Tony lost her
serpent side when things became hot and
heavy with Cheryl tell me in the
comments but now let's shift away from
all that serpent tension and focus on
the sexual attention of our Riverdale
couples in seven seconds in heaven well
we didn't get our highly anticipated
bug-head reunion moment we did get an
unexplained scene of Jughead waking up
in Betty's bed so there's that yay also
jugheads Bed Head is priceless then over
in virtue land oh wait there is no
barchi land in this episode say bon
voyage shippers cuz we've got a new port
in Riverdale the veggie garden only the
best at labahn Louie after weeks of
suspecting it Veronica and Reggie
finally took the first step in their new
relationship and they sealed it with a
sweet and sultry kiss so how do we all
feel about this new official ship well
I'll tell you that star Charles Melton
is all for it I hopped on the phone with
him and here's what he told me when I
asked him to kiss and tell about that
scene Charles said quote it was kind of
exciting because we knew that this
build-up this relationship was going to
happen and for a while we thought it was
going to be a couple episodes previous
when Reggie and Veronica were going to
seal the deal with a kiss
so there was a lot of kind of like
leading up to that it was just very
beautiful and very sensual I think we
were very excited filming that scene all
the fans were gonna see you Reggie and
Veronica and last but not least this was
our most Shoni filled episode of the
season we got some ultra flirtatious
looks a bit of sexy time unzipping x'
and forbidden hand-holding bite me moose
but the biggest and most monumental
Shoni surprise of the night was when
tony and cheryl exchanged those three
swarthy little words
you love you oh it almost makes up for
the fact that they were kicked out of
the serpents almost and on that note
let's unleash our rage and delight from
episode 309 in hisses and kisses now it
may be a new year but my top is that the
episode is still going to Hyrum Lodge I
don't even need to explain it anymore
next up I can't believe I'm gonna say
this but hisses to Cheryl excuse me I
was not a fan of the way she was acting
in this episode bombshell you have
plenty of money why not give everything
you were stealing over to the serpents
who actually need it it's getting cold
out and the rest of us don't get to go
back to thistle house also because of
Cheryl's brazen behavior and complete
disrespect of the rules Tony lost her
place in the serpents are you guys
frustrated with Cheryl are you sending
hisses to Jughead tell me in the
comments below
hisses to all the none drama and the
sisters of quiet mercy kids I know I'm
supposed to feel sorry for them but by
the end of the episode I was just really
tired of them leeching onto Betty I'm
almost glad the Edgar came and swept
them off to the farm because it means
worse one step closer to finally going
there
trust me the farm is not safe hisses to
the henchmen known as the gargoyle gang
at this point I honestly missed the
Ghoulies because at least I could take
them seriously what's with the masks you
guys and did you borrow that voice
changer from the green arrow you have
filled this city and hisses to Archie's
ghostly grim game of Griffins and
gargoyles I just found it frustrating
especially the black hood and back part
but switching it over to kisses the only
thing that I did like about Archie's
game was watching Hyrum get stabbed
oh and scene Jughead Betty Ann
Veronica's iconic looks and innocent
behavior from the pilot have you been
working on any new songs arch I'd love
to hear some of them now take a look at
what KJ app' had to tell me when we
chatted about Archie's insane journey in
this episode start about 309 when Archie
eventually ends up playing J&G what was
that like for you to finally get to
experience that it was cold it allowed
us to kind of shoot some pretty
interesting stuff where he's kind of
hallucinating a little bit because of
what happens in the
I don't know if he was actually dreaming
or Freddie actually happened but yeah it
was fun yeah
Vegas didn't not help at all really when
he getting attacked by the bear I mean
isn't that why you have a dog too like
how you protect you and stuff but he was
chilling he's hidden it comes inside
wagging his tail I'm like hop did when
you read that it was gonna be our tubers
yeah oh definitely they just came out of
nowhere
for sure no I'm stuck with scars for the
rest of my life you have like a bird
mark on your hip you're not a serpent
tattoo they're just really going for it
putting so much on you man you don't
want to be doing many more of those
shirtless scenes cuz then they gotta add
it so much in the hair [ __ ] they'll be
there he'll always be there keeping it
going with kisses I loved getting more
Josie in this episode especially her
sultry cabaret voice
yes please kisses to Veronica for
destroying that stupid egg it was ugly
anyways to sing more from Alice Cooper
and her fabulous hair and kisses to the
return of Nana Rose kisses to all of our
new relationship developments with
veggie and Shoni
to bug heads surprise bedtime cuddles
and to Vegas for being the sweetest
little punk and we'll end it there
now thank you all so much for watching
this after-show with me and tune in next
time for our Sweetwater secrets preview
for episode 310 chapter 45 the stranger
for a special sneak peek on what's ahead
now if you had fun filming with me then
please give this video a like and then
hit subscribe so you never miss an
episode and now I want you all to
unleash your hisses and kisses for me in
the comments below last time you left
over a thousand so keep it up did you
like this episode are you really worried
about Archie's fate how do you feel
about Sheryl and Tony getting kicked out
of the serpent's who are you most
frustrated with and what did you think
of Veronica and Reggie's first kiss tell
me what you think and I'll see you next
time river babes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]